an atlanta mayoral candidate who voted
to sequester 73 million dollars from the
city's police department budget
reportedly had his car stolen
it's time that we start addressing the
root of this problem because there's no
amount of officers that could have
stopped this from happening
play stupid games win stupid prizes i
mean it's it's truly incredible how
these blue cities are starting to fall
apart
in chicago chicago has now announced
their police department just announced
that they are changing their policy with
regard to foot pursuits
hey what is their new policy with regard
to foot purses you want to talk about
allowing criminality to flourish
their policy with regard to foot
pursuits is that foot pursuits will only
be allowed when there is quote probable
cause for an arrest
or it is believed an individual has
committed is committing or is about to
commit
a crime there will be no foot chases
stemming from minor traffic offenses
so if somebody is speeding and they get
out of their car and they run
the police are not allowed to change
them chase them
chicago mayor lori lightfoot said
because foot pursuits are one of the
most dangerous actions police officers
can engage in we can't afford to wait
any longer to put a policy in place that
regulates them
the important parameters outlined in
this policy will not only protect our
officers the public
and potential suspects during foot
pursuits it also serves as a step
forward in our mission to modernize and
reform
our police department the interim plan
includes the following
reminding officers to begin any
interaction with tactics meant to reduce
the possibility of a foot pursuit
defining foot pursuits as appropriate
only when there is probable cause for
an arrest or it is believed an
individual has committed is committing
or is about to commit a crime
prohibiting foot pursuits stemming from
minor traffic offenses
detailing tactics to avoid a put a foot
pursuit including
continual communication with the subject
and encouraging officers to position
themselves
in such a way to reduce the opportunity
for a foot chase
outlining alternatives to foot pursuits
that should always be considered by
officers including
establishing a surveillance or
containment area and or apprehending an
identified suspect at another time or
place so otherwise
let the guy go let him run away
committed a crime
but you know what is it really worth it
basically what this does is it creates
liability for an officer deciding
to pursue but no liability for letting
the guy go
that's the incentive structure that has
now been created for chicago cops if you
follow the guy you're not going to have
to justify to the police department why
you engaged in a flip pursuit but
if you just let the criminal go and he
goes and he shoots somebody you can
always say well you know what
i really didn't think a foot pursuit was
appropriate i wasn't sure he was going
to go commit a crime
okay the benefit of the doubt used to be
with the cops
okay and you may say there was too much
benefit of the doubt to the cops
that's an argument but the alternative
it seems
is benefit of the doubt to the criminals
because once you tell cops they can just
not do their jobs
and in fact it is dangerous for them to
do their jobs they're not going to do
their jobs
the new chicago policy prohibits foot
pursuits for criminal offenses less than
a class a misdemeanor unless the person
poses an obvious threat to the community
or any person
and discontinuing foot pursuits if
someone is injured and requires
immediate medical attention
if officers are unaware of their
location and if the need to apprehend
the suspect
the subject is not worth the risk to
responding officers the public or the
subject
okay that's that's the one that's just
wild okay so you're supposed to stop a
foot pursuit
if the need to apprehend the subject is
not worth the risk
to the officers or the public
or the person you are pursuing so in
other words if you're chasing down
a person for say smoking pot in public
and let's say that's a
class a misdemeanor in chicago i don't
know what the actual classification is
and the person starts to run away okay
if you believe
that you may have to tackle the person
or if you believe that the person who
knows might be carrying a gun and they
might turn around and you might have to
shoot the person
then you're supposed to discontinue the
foot pursuit
termination of a foot pursuit of
officers engaged in the pursuit believed
they would not be able to control the
suspect
if a confrontation were to occur well i
mean that's literally the suspect has a
gun i can't control the subject
right so i i mean this is madness so the
city of chicago
is now by the way supervisors are also
made liable for this because now
supervisors are allowed to instruct
officers to discontinue a foot pursuit
at any time and anytime there's a foot
pursuit officers have to notify the
office of emergency management and
communications
all of this was done in the aftermath of
the fatal police shooting of 13 year old
adam toledo who pulled who was holding
a gun and was shooting random cars
passing by
so this is all designed to prevent the
shooting of adam toledo who was
in fact engaging in deadly type criminal
behavior shooting guns at passing cars
is a deadly type criminal behavior
and the city of chicago solution is tell
the cops you stop engaging in foot
pursuits
how could anything like this can you
imagine why the cities are getting worse
how could they possibly be getting worse
hell
okay well play stupid games win stupid
prizes is the name of the game
over in atlanta which is pursuing
similar policies
according to the new york post an
atlanta mayoral candidate who voted to
sequester 73 million dollars from the
city's police department budget
reportedly had his car stolen
by a group of young thieves this week
and wound up thanking the cops for their
help
city council member antonio brown had
just gotten out of his white mercedes
coupe to speak to fellow community
leader
ben norman in northwest atlanta's dixie
hills community wednesday when he
spotted four or five kids the youngest
only six or seven
the kids were walking around a store and
within seconds they jumped inside his
car
one kid was in the driver's seat brown
told the outlet ben attempted to open
the door to get him out of the car he
fought
with ben i then engaged and tried to get
him out of the car the three other kids
were trying to figure out how to get in
the car or stay out of the car he
started to hit on the gas and ben let it
go
as he started to speed up and if i knew
i had not let it go i knew i could
probably have killed myself because he
was going so fast i would have started
to tumble he said and i would have heard
him
brown said he filed a report with the
atlanta pd
you know again brown voted to defund the
police
what did brown say he said it appears
the kids acted out of desperation he
said this is a generational poverty
issue
these kids it's 12 30 in the afternoon
why aren't they in school why aren't we
enforcing systems to ensure that if
they're not in school they're in rec
centers
or again you could just tell the cops
never to enforce the law and the
predictable result is they will steal
your car
okay so play stupid games win stupid
prizes
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier
that is just science